. We have a voicemail number and that number is
two one nine two. David P. Here's a question that
I can't tell if it's good faith or not, but
there's a lot of meaty policy discussion
that we can have as a result.
Take a look at this question.
Hey, David, a man, the anti intellectual.
I have a question for you. Right. Why do
Democrats insist on having Medicare
for all when the medical industry
is more concerned with treating symptoms
with medications instead of addressing the
underlying cause? I'd like to hear some of that.
So, you know, the fact that they call themselves
man the anti intellectual makes me think maybe
this is not someone who's actually contacting me
in good faith. But these are good questions. One
of the real problems with the medical industry and
there's there's two different reasons for this,
is that the overwhelming focus is on symptoms
and and immediate causes rather than maybe
underlying causes. And this applies to, you know,
so many different conditions caused by obesity
or a sedentary lifestyle or whatever the case
may be. That's a problem. And one of the things
that can be done to resolve that issue is to go
sorry. There's one other part of the
problem, which is for the most part,
doctors are paid for doing things to the
patient. You get paid or someone gets paid.
Payments happen for ordering tests, for doing
procedures, et cetera, rather than how healthy
can we keep this person so that they don't need as
much medical care as we might be able to sign them
up for. There are some insurance co-ops and in
certain states there are systems being developed
where doctors are compensated for keeping people
healthy rather than for the number of things that
they ought to be done. But the question is
an interesting one, because what he seems to
be saying is that's how the system works. If you
do Medicare for all, that issue just gets worse.
No, no, no, no, no. One of the ideas of Medicare
for all, whether it's a national Medicare for
all or a state run Medicare for all, is that
you could actually change reimbursement policy
and payment systems so that you start
rewarding doctors for keeping patients
healthy rather than reimbursing them. Based on how
many different tests and procedures can you order.
So there are two different issues and it does
not follow logically that Medicare for all
would simply mean an exacerbation of the broken
system that we now have. And it's important when
assuming that that was a good faith question
and maybe I'm silly for for assuming that
these these are two different things. And
I would argue that the issue of treating
symptoms and profiting from doing stuff could
be more easily fixed under a Medicare for all
system. And it's been widely studied and we've
talked about it before on the bonus show today,
Kentucky's Senate has voted to make it a crime to
taunt or insult. Law enforcement officers, will
this be made law and what are the implications
and are there actual free speech implications so
often when the right says that's a First Amendment
violation has nothing to do with the government?
What about this? We are going to talk about that
on the bonus show. Number two, Spain is going
to launch a trial of a four day working week, not
the whole country, but in Spain, there is a trial.
And we've been interested in this topic for
some time. We're going to talk about it.
And Capitol Police, for all of the people asking,
how long is the National Guard going to be in
D.C.? How long are these fences going to be up?
Capitol Police is now moving forward on a plan to
remove the outer fence and to make other security
changes and hopefully assuming it's safe to do so.
That security presence in Washington, D.C., is
going to start being diminished. And we're going
to talk about it's become highly politicized.
There's a lot of political implications to what
is going on there. And the right has been bomb
throwing quite a bit about National Guard in D.C.,
seemingly forgetting that the reason the National
Guard is there is because of what the right did
on January 6th. So all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show get instant access by
signing up at Join Pakman dot com. You can
also get access by making a five dollar
a month or greater pledge on Patreon at
patriation dot com The David Pakman Show.
I will see you then or otherwise
back on tomorrow's show.